APPROVED A PLAN TO COMPLETE A
SECTION OF THE ARIZONA BORDER.
HERE TO REACT IS FORMER FED AND
ARIZONA NATIONAL GUARD AND U.S.
SENATE CANDIDATE RETIRED GENERAL
MICK MCGUIRE.
SO NICE TO HAVE YOU ON THE SHOW
THIS MORNING.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SAYING MARK
KELLY, THE SENATOR OF ARIZONA IS
IN BIG TROUBLE AND THIS IS WHY
THE PRESIDENT HAS APPROVED THIS
LITTLE BIT OF WALL IN ARIZONA TO
BE BUILT.
YOU AGREE?
>> GOOD MORNING, RACHEL.
I DO AGREE.
THIS IS THE HEIGHT OF HYPOCRISY.
CLEARLY THIS IS A POLITICAL
STUNT.
THAT SAID EVERY ONE OF US IN
ARIZONA, EVERY ONE OF US LIKE ME
WHO HAS GENERATIONS OF FAMILY
HERE IN THIS STATE HAVE NEVER
SEEN THIS LEVEL OF LAWLESSNESS.
YOU HEARD LAWRENCE AND BRIAN
JUST TALKING BEFORE THIS THAT IF
YOU DO NOT ENFORCE THE RULE OF
LAW.
THE COUNTRY AS WE KNOW IT WILL
COME APART AT THE SEAMS AND
THAT'S WHY I'M RUNNING FOR U.S.
SENATE AND WHEN PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT, RACHEL, COME ON YOUR SHOW
AND TALK ABOUT IT'S INHUMANE TO
BUILD A WALL.
ASK THEM IS IT INHUMANE TO HAVE
OVER 40 PEOPLE DIE IN THE
MORALES SAN SECTOR DIE THIS YEAR
CROSSING THE BORDER?
CHILDREN, YOUNG CHILDREN AND
WOMEN, IT'S COMPLETELY LAWLESS
IN THIS AREA.
THIS SECTION OF WALL NEEDS TO
GET DONE.
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO NEEDS TO
GET RE-INSTATED AND REACTIVATE
THE 1,030 GUARDSMAN UNDER MY
COMMAND THAT JOE BIDEN ZEROED
OUT AND DERELICT THE DUTY.
RACHEL: THIS IS THE ONE THAT'S
VERY HONESTLY A BROKER ABOUT THE
BORDER.
HENRY HAS BEEN CHALLENGING HIS
PARTY AND ASKING BIDEN AND
KAMALA TO COME DOWN AND SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON.
HAS MARK KELLY DONE ANYTHING OF
THOSE THINGS AND WHAT IS HIS
RECORD AS AN ARIZONA SENATOR ON
THE BORDER?
>> WELL, HE'S COMING UP ON TWO
YEARS IN OFFICE.
SHORTLY AFTER HE WAS ELECTED IN
THE SPECIAL ELECTION, HE TALKED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE WANTED TO
STUDY THE PROBLEM.
RACHEL, I CAN TAKE YOU DOWN TO
THE MORALES SAN SECTOR TODAY, IF
WE RE-I'VE IN THE NEXT HOUR,
WITHIN THE NEXT TWO TO THREE
HOURS, HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WOULD
BE STREAMING ACROSS DROPPING
PAPERS AND ENTERING THEIR
POCKETS BEFORE THEY CROSS THE
GAPS IN THE WALL ALL BEING
TRAFFICKED BY THE CARTELS.
THE LAWLESS BEHAVIOR HAS
ESCALATED INTO HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND ESCALATION IN DRUG
SMUGGLING, CHINA IS COMPLIES SIT
IN THIS WITH THE PRODUCTION OF
NETTAL AND HUNDREDS -- FENTANYL
PRECUR SOSS AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS ARE DYING
FROM OVERDOSES AND MARK KELLY
WANTED TO STUDY THIS PROBLEM
WHEN HE ARRIVED IN OFFICE.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE TERRIFIED.
THE BIG MONEY PEOPLE ARE
TERRIFIED, THE ESTABLISHMENT IS
TERRIFIED OF MY SUCCESS TAKING
HIM ON IN NOVEMBER BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO BREAK THIS CYCLE.
RACHEL: THE U.S. GOVERNMENT IS
COMPLICIT AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US, MICK,
AND GOOD LUCK IN THE PRIMARY.
>> YOU BET.
EVERYBODY GET OUT AND VOTE,
AUGUST 2, TUESDAY IS A BIG
PRIMARY AND, RACHEL, I LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING BACK ON YOUR
SHOW TO TALK ABOUT